For years, Sony has tried to launch a Spider-Verse to call its own.
Some have been good,
some have been bad,
some have been Venom.
And some never even started swinging.
Now, they're back, with an all-new strategy.
Saying f*** it and doing all the spider stuff at once.
Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse.
Strap in with this fresh take on your favorite neighborhood superhero.
That's probably one of the best movies of 2018.
But it's... got a lot of...
spiders in it?
I dunno.
This movie's a work of art, man.
Maybe I'll just run out the clock on this one by pushing random buttons in my booth.
Hmmm.
What's this one do?
Uh, that's not a good sound.
Whoa! I don't think I'm in my recording booth anymore.
Who are you?
I'm Epic Geek Girl, the voice of Honest Trailers from an alternate dimension.
Just sunny, upbeat, and emotionally healthier.
And...?
And what? That's all the explanation the movie gave.
Want to team up for this one?
Heck yeah!
Suit up for a fresh new take on the Spider-Man franchise
that combines jaw-dropping camerawork and fever dream visuals
with a multicultural hip-hop fueled New York that proves Sony product placement is the one constant in the multiverse.
To create a mold breaking superhero story with the meta of Deadpool and Lego Batman.
Save it for Comic-Con.
What's Comic-Con?
The heart of Superman
and the visual style of Pix--
Actually, this movie doesn't look anything like the animation we've gotten used to.
Does every animated character in your reality do the eyebrows thing too?
Yep.
Uhhh.
This booth is getting kind of crowded.
Who are you three?
I'm the Epic Dungeon Master, a far traveler from a distant realm who earns his keep being critical about movies.
G'day.
I'm Australian voice guy.
I'm Australian.
Huh. How's that work?
Booobs.
- Ohhh.
- That makes sense.
- Yeah, that works.
Shall we continue this quest?
Let's do this.
Park your Peters, because there's an all-new Spider-Man on the block.
Miles Morales.
He's a relatable, sweet, nerdy high school kid that was bitten by a radioactive spider.
Wait...
How is he all-new?
This Spider-Man...
likes Post Malone?
- Oh ok.
- Yeah, makes sense.
- Completely different.
But you won't want to walk a mile in his loose-fitting shoes.
Because this spider guy doesn't just have one coming-of-age problem.
He's got all of them.
From dealing with his demanding dad
Finding his artistic voice
To fitting in at a new school
Living away from home for the first time
And puberty
It's a puberty thing.
I don't know why I said that.
Crikey! Just so puberty!
Please stop sticking.
But Miles isn't alone on his spider quest.
Because plenty of spider folk are joining his party.
From the hot bod version
to the dad bod version
Sometimes I let matches burn down to my fingertips just to feel something, anything.
John Mulaney, playing himself.
I just washed my hands, that's why they're wet.
And one that's so anime I'm amazed she's not licensed by Funimation.
Together, they'll battle all-new takes on classic spider bad guys.
Like the chaotic neutral and completely terrifying Prowler
And the sexy cat lady version of Doc Ock
All led by the Kingpin.
A tragic villain mourning the loss of his wife, his son,
and his neck.
Hey, don't take my punchlines in my own booth!
Sorry mate, sorry.
Ugh, this is a mess!
How did the movie keep all this manageable?
So take the leap with a movie that sounded like a terrible idea when you first heard about it.
But ended up being so good we can't wait for more Miles
Or Gwen Stacy
Or whatever they throw at us
I'm down.
Down Under.
Get it? I'm Australian.
Except for that one.
Well guys...
It's been fun, but it's time to wrap up.
How do you want to do this?
You know, you guys could always stay.
We could be an epic voice family.
Sorry mate, kangaroos to box.
Until we meet again, my friend.
Is it Tuesday yet?
Plus if we stay here our atoms will explode, so later nerd!
Bye Felicia
Oh man.
I hope they come back soon.
Because I'm not watching the Jared Leto Morbius movie by myself.
Thanks to my epic voice-verse friend, Felicia Day.
Check out her new sci-fi comedy podcast, voyage to the stars.
Wherever you get your podcasts.
And to Matt Mercer.
To learn more about Critical Role in the Kickstarter for their animated series, visit critrole.com
Is the first episode of our new series Fandom Uncovered about Twilight fans?
Yes.
Do we have a healthy history with Twilight?
No.
But should you check out the show anyway?
Yes, yes, and yes.
So click the box to watch now.
Beetlejuice Beetlejuice Beetlejuice
Winter is comings